Brother,
my brother
isn't with so much more. Tell me why.
>> You ever thought about why magic has to
be about fighting? Why? Can't it just be
about peace, sunshines, and rainbows?
Imagine we're always asking how. How do
we get value? How to win? But never.
Why? Have you considered how much
resources we are wasting on fighting
combat? You play a creature, I play a
creature, I attack, you block. What
happens? Let me check the new player
guide. Power, toughness, toughness,
power. Oh, they both die. Well, that's a
lot of nothing. But apparently, combat
is where games are won and lost. And
it's not just the removals and combat
tricks we have to load up on because of
that. Look at our creatures. How many of
them are you playing? Because they're
excellent attackers or blockers. Now
imagine a life without combat.
Say you know a guy who knows a guy with
a certain background and he can just
take care of fighting for you. All of it
automated. No more complicated maths and
number checking. No more need for
whining. Why are you attacking me, not
him? Imagine with me. This is Jin with
Next Level Commander and this is a very
special video for me. Thank you for
joining me on the first installment of
my commander ccentric content. It is
about my favorite style of deck building
where you lean very heavily on your
commander depending on it for value,
removal, win condition, and sometimes
all of the above. I enjoy
commandercentric decks because they can
play like the commanders themselves
rather than following traditional
archetypes. Every deck is distinct, like
a fighting game character with a limited
but specialized set of moves. While your
opponents may know exactly what you have
in your arsenal, it still can be a
challenge for them to navigate around
it. If you're interested in this kind of
deck building, please subscribe for
more. Some examples here include a croak
set deck using all distant tomb and
undying effects and get rock the
ravenous ride with all pump spells,
protection spells, and elves. But today
we have Both. Yeah, remember when I said
we're magicking peacefully? Just
kidding. We are Mewtwo. Our opponents
fight gladiator style while we eat
popcorn and commentate on their combat
decisions. And that is our entire game
plan with the background noble heritage
bailoff will start at four power and
continue to grow every turn. This is
also a really interesting combination
because unlike other tempts, most of the
time it's correct for your opponents to
take the deal if they have no way to
remove bailoff and has to attack someone
else anyways. Might as well grow their
creatures and hope to use it against us
later on, right? And this is great
because our opponents are hitting each
other so much harder until they can get
out of our cage. But wait, you ask. What
if there's only one opponent left? Gold
no longer works as intended. What will
we do with our commander? His ability
doesn't do anything now, and it's only a
1215.
Oh, right. So, yeah. Both. Both does
everything. All eggs in a Bothshaped
basket. And we better keep that basket
steady with protection spells. And just
like Mewtwo, we do things in moderation.
Only 27 pieces of protection. Yes, 27.
Take that deck building templates. This
may sound ridiculous at first, but
imagine a board and hand like this.
You're probably feeling pretty safe for
the next few turns, maybe even rest of
the game. It's the liberation from
combat. We have so many extra card
slots. And this allows us to go deep.
Shelter in light a Johnny's presence and
emerge unscathed. A lot of these are
fringe. Even someone as obsessed with
protection as myself never used these
elsewhere. And here is because we have
to be careful with phasing and blinking
effects. These are usually the superior
protection spells, but problem is blink
removes the counters accumulated on
bailoff and phasin takes them out of the
game until our next turn and we can't do
that if we're threatened on board. So
yeah, shroud hexroof protection from a
color, all that good stuff. We still
have a few blink and phasing effects
because they can be excellent in the
right scenarios, but definitely keep the
downsides in mind. Now on to the fun
part, utilities. First off, we're in
borrow, so we do have to jump through
some hoops for card draw. Monarch is
actually perfect for this deck. So,
we've got Court of Grace and Ember Wild
Captain both synergize well with our
play style. Aurelia, the law above is
interesting. We shouldn't have too much
trouble attacking with three creatures
ourselves to get that one card, but if
we can get just one more from our
opponents, smacking each other is well
worth playing. And now, a few toys to
really power up our golding blind
obedience. I don't usually play this
card. I don't think it does enough, but
it's perfect in this deck. Yeah, playing
creatures to block for a turn. Huh, not
happening. Duelist Heritage, excellent
finisher for closing out games with our
commander, but also being able to do
this on opponents combat is massive.
Death Kiss. Everyone is dying twice as
fast. And we can go a few things in a
pinch. Like if Sam plays a BFM, oh, what
would I do with that? Bailoff is not
keeping that in check. We can just kiss
it. My personal favorite though is
bothersome quaset. No one is blocking
ever. And in the rare scenario of us
losing our commander, yeah, remember our
27 protection spells, most of them are
none creature. So, say we block a thing
with quaset, give it protection and gold
something big from the third player.
Yeah, this can definitely hold the fort
for a little while. And just a few more
panic buttons, we have spectacular
showdown. The overloaded effect will end
the game fast with proper timing. And
once in a while, we can just use the
base effect on bailoff to kill one
player. It's perfectly doable. There's
also disrupt the cororum, taunt from the
ramp part, and of course, the one ring.
We really do need the draw power. Lamb
attacks and weathered wafer are absolute
staples and boros. Now, one problem with
this deck I found is that I'm relying
very heavily on Noble Heritage to pump
our commander. Sometimes it gets
removed. Sometimes the pump isn't fast
enough. So, we do need just a few backup
plants. So, the most efficient one here
is Blackblade Reforged. Five mana,
usually 10 extra power. Good card. And
the best possible equipment in a borrow
deck is Sunforger. The plus four is
handy, but in the late game, this card
will alone will keep us in any attrition
war. In the Sunforger package, we have
Acromo's Will, which needs no
introduction. It does everything.
Tibball's trickery to answer the
otherwise unanswerable and rest of the
package consists of the aforementioned
protection spells and of course
removals. Yeah, look at this one. Final
showdown. This is a protection spell or
a one-sided board wipe and it can be sun
forgered. Yeah, holy crap. Parting gust
is a cute one here, serving as a removal
or a slow blink. Hard wipes. We're using
the most efficient ones in blasphemous
act and vanquish the horde. Chandra's
ignition works really well with our
commander. Imagine lifelinking with a 10
power bale into this. Route is always
good. Imagine your opponents finally
disassembling your commander to alpha
strike you and just to run into this.
Brutal. For rocks, we have the typical
but a few interesting ones like All Fate
Scroll. At this point, it's like my
channel's icon. It's so good. Curse of
opulence is perfect for this deck if
opponents have to smack each other
anyways. I mean, they might as well get
a treasure out of it. Sure. The Iron
Craig is a really underrated rock. It's
mana when you need it, and it pumps the
commander when you don't. Interestingly,
I read this card wrong for the longest
time. I thought it shut down the
equipped creatures abilities, and even
then, I thought it was playable in some
decks, but turns out it's referring to
itself, so it's just no longer a mana
rock. Excellent card. And Bender's Water
Skin. This is the exact kind of deck
that wants this card. It allows us to
drop our commander with protection mana
up two turns early. Lens have to pull a
lot of weight in Boros. And for utility
lands, we're playing the ones that pump
baleof. Opal, tyrate sanctum do solid
work. Slayer stronghold is a temporary
pump, but also gives haste, which works
really well here. We have a few other
haste lens, and we're not using these on
our own creatures usually, but the ones
our opponents drop and intend to block
with. Nope, we smashing. War Room and
Bonder's Enclave are a bit expensive to
use, but were essentially a control
deck, often with mana open. So, sinking
mana into these once in a while is
excellent value. And there you have it.
This is the Both deck. It's not the most
explosive build. Both takes a little
while to set up. So, while while we do
that, we may need to play tight and
answer some early threats. But once we
have Both set up, we'll be coasting.
Keep him alive. Send him in for some
commander damage here and there to set
up for the onehit kill in the late game.
I try my best to make the deck
resilient, but Boros does have its
limitations. The budget is mid, but only
because of a handful of replaceable
cards. A budget version of this is
definitely doable, and you won't lose
too much power. The current list I'm
keeping around bracket three, but most
of my friends don't follow brackets for
good reasons, I'd say. So, I toss in a
farewell of trouble in Paris when I do
play. I'd say the deck is fairly
allrounded against different opponents.
It feels like cheating when you're
playing against aggro and beatdown
decks. And against the less permanent
based ones, they will also be pressured
by other opponents smacking into them
willingly or otherwise. And they also
have to figure out ways to block
baleiff. So if this is something you
would enjoy playing, give it a try and
let me know how it goes. And thank you
for joining me for the first episode of
our commander centric series. The best
stuff is yet to come. Please subscribe
and I'll be seeing you soon.